Christians worldwide are about to
celebrate the birth of Jesus in
Bethlehem more than two thousand years
ago
the historic city is enjoying its
busiest year on record for tourists Seth
Doane traveled there to see the
Christmas celebrations get underway and
met a group of Americans who made the
spiritual journey
Seth then took a tour of modern-day
Bethlehem a city with a history as old
as the Bible in the hills outside
Bethlehem some ways of life haven't
changed much in 2,000 years a Shepherd
tends to his flock in a scene
reminiscent of biblical times not far
away in the heart of modern Bethlehem's
densely packed Town Center the Church of
the Nativity marks what the faithful
celebrate as Jesus's birth place inside
filing down into the grotto where it
said that manger once was we met a group
of Americans Karen McCarty made her
pilgrimage from Fort Worth Texas we
watched you in there singing you got
teary why well in the follow Jesus and
it's very special to be where he was
born
Bethlehem today is under the Palestinian
Authority over the years it's been
occupied by Ottomans British Jordanians
and Israelis and that culture mix pours
under the street there's chicken
shawarma
and falafels trinkets for tourists and
this unlikely stop for some pilgrims
Christian tattoo artist Waleed Abu Yash
says he's drawn thousands of these
crosses William Hanna from Southern
California told us why he was getting
his to show all all my friends look what
I did look what I went the way I have
it's a permanent way to mark a
pilgrimage it's something like holy I'm
making a tattoo yeah in a whole place
its holy and a hot spot for clashes
between Palestinians and Israelis as we
witnessed reporting here last year
now there's okay now project projectiles
have just been thrown in our direction
we're moving back with many of the
Palestinians here who are retreating
from where the Israelis are tempers
flared in the wake of the u.s. decision
to move its embassy from Tel Aviv to the
contested city of Jerusalem which
neighbors Bethlehem but is sealed off
from it one prominent feature of the
modern Bethlehem landscape is this giant
separation barrier which the Israelis
started building back in 2002 as a
security measure it effectively cuts off
the Palestinian territories from Israel
the separation barriers here the hotels
here this is not a typical place for a
hotel this is the point this was banks
his idea Banksy the secretive British
Street artist developed the walled off
hotel which advertises the world's worst
view it's both place to stay and
political statement he tried to profess
the war throw at Hotel hotel manager
Wisam salsa grew up here he pointed to
where Banksy painted angels trying to
pull the wall apart this is commentary
on refugees inside the hotel the artists
continued to
Volk this is david by mantlet
Michelangelo but you can see that tear
gas is we asked if by using violence
Palestinians made this barrier necessary
I think more oppression raised the
chance of violence in the future gazing
out at the separation barrier these
Belgian tourists told us they'd come to
Bethlehem for the Contemporary Art but
were drawn in by its history and
something more to come here is like
opening a door because I'm not really
really religiously minded but here I
think you can feel a little bit of the
history I think I feel the roots I must
be coming from here there certainly was
a distinctive spirit in the air at
Bethlehem's Christmas tree lighting a
modern mix of cultures and traditions
all sharing a connection to this ancient
place for CBS this morning Seth Doane
Bethlehem love the idea you come for the
art you learn the history or if you're
coming for that history the Waldorf
Hotel I think I'll stay there
works for me